i think it is bold and powerful to admit
to using in your private life the drugs
that you study in your research
including heroin and cocaine so let me
ask
what is the experience of taking heroin
like what happens to the body what
happens to the mind when you take it
well you know i take mdma cannabis and
all the rest of these drugs too i've
tried those drugs um the experience in
the body and the mind i i don't really
know what people want to know and in
that regard it's like saying what is the
experience of having an orgasm
in the body in the mind or or some other
sort of event that you really enjoy
um so i don't really know what people
said what poetry is for for describing
these kinds of experiences i mean i
guess
uh given mdma given psilocybin
in the full context of that maybe it's
more useful to say
what are the
differences in experiences that your
mind goes through uh like chemically
biologically
uh so it's like keeping it strictly to
the sort of the
the the biology of it versus the full
environmental human experience yeah see
this is a mistake that people make all
the time they try to act as if biology
is the only determinant of drug effects
and that's just not how it works uh you
need the environment you need the cage
as they say if you don't have the cage
you don't get the full extent of the
effects and so like you can take mdma
and have an awful time you can have a
time in which uh which you get paranoid
and so forth and then
you can take it that drug under the
right conditions and it just be like one
of the best moments you've ever had it
certainly enhanced
um a number of my relationships but i've
also had some times with mdma that
haven't been so lovely when the people
who you are hanging out with
you don't know them you're distrustful
and all of those kind of things so
it's important to put context in it now
we can talk about drugs at a biochemical
level at a biological level and we kind
of do that in this country with this
fascination with neuroscience
and um
that's an inappropriate kind of
fascination the way in the way we talk
about it so we can talk about opioids
and then we can talk about
endogenous opioid system in the brain we
can talk about dopamine and other sort
of
monoamine transmitters and and what uh
opioids are doing to them and we can do
the same thing with mdma
and
we won't be any closer to understanding
the sort of uh
experience that uh is induced by these
drugs certainly the experience that we
all seek you know what i'm saying so
getting a positive experience or getting
a negative experience is strongly
defined by the environment
strongly dependent upon that but the
environment is a very
it's a short word that can describe a
lot of things
so
would you say the environment is
important are the people
where you are currently in your life
or is it also dependent on the full
trajectory of your psychology of your
life experiences of your parents or the
people you came up with of the trauma
you've experienced of the hopes and
dreams that were crushed or
or or not or the opposite or the success
levels or all those things like what
what are the interesting sort of uh
landscape of experiences that contribute
to how you actually
feel when you take a drug right on so
all of those things are important but
you know like if someone had trauma in
childhood and they did the work and they
dealt with it that's not so important in
this case but if they didn't deal with
it and that trauma is being triggered in
that event
in that moment
then it's important but let's just take
somebody like me
i'm 54 years old i'll be 55 this month
actually and um
you know i've done a lot of work in
terms of figuring out who i am and i'm
comfortable with myself
and i know how to set limits for
whatever it is i'm doing
um and so
i know i need to work out i know i need
to eat well i know i need to sleep well
i know i need to be in an environment
with people
within my trust
and then if all of those things are met
oh it's likely to be a good time you
know what i'm saying but if i haven't
slept if i haven't worked out if i don't
feel good
um it won't be a good time but uh i try
and be responsible and take care of my
uh eating habits sleeping habits make
sure my responsibilities are taken care
of and so when i'm in that moment
i just uh enjoy that moment i'm there
i'm not thinking about a bill that i
didn't paid i'm not thinking about um oh
i forgot to do this for my kid i'm not
thinking about that because all of those
things are taken care of if they're not
taken care of it will impact the
experience and it may negatively impact
the experience
well that is the counterintuitive even
controversial finding from your recent
book so we should kind of
i know it seems obvious to you but i
think a lot of people hearing this would
think it's quite non-obvious so um
in your new book drug use for grown-ups
you write
for the findings section i discovered
that the predominant effects produced by
the drugs discussed in this book are
positive
i it didn't matter whether the drug in
question was cannabis cocaine heroin
methamphetamine or psilocybin
overwhelmingly consumers express feeling
more altruistic empathetic euphoric
focused grateful and tranquil
they also experience enhanced social
interactions a great sense of purpose
and meaning and increased sexual
intimacy and performance this console
this constellation of findings
challenged my original beliefs about
drugs and their effects
i had been indoctrinated to be biased
toward the negative effects of drug use
but over the past two plus decades i had
gained a deeper more nuanced
understanding
these words are very counter-intuitive
to a lot of people
um
i think like you also mentioned in the
book and elsewhere you know people have
come around to maybe psilocybin
uh being one such drug maybe cannabis
being once this drug but you also
mention other drugs like cocaine heroin
methamphetamine
um
can you just linger on this point
how
uh do we get the positive effects of
those drugs and why in the media and the
general conception we have of these
drugs is that they were going to
um
make a bad life worse or ruin a good
life
well so your first question was how do
we
harness the positive effects how do we
increase the likelihood of getting the
positive effects again like i said we
want to make sure that people are
responsible
and they've handled their
responsibilities make sure they eat well
sleep will exercise all of those sorts
of things play an important point role
and also if they know exactly what
they're getting and then they're not
paranoid about oh it's something
contaminated in some adulteration in my
drug
so you want to make sure you know
exactly what you have once you satisfy
those kind of things you understand the
dose and potency you understand all
those things to decrease any sort of
anxiety you might have about the
substance itself
it increases the likelihood that you
will have a better time so anxiety is
the big one you need to remove the
anxiety anxiety is critical
it's huge
many of the negative effects that we see
with drugs have to do with anxiety and
not necessarily anxiety because the drug
induced it's the anxiety that the
situation induced a lot of times
and then you ask like well why does this
sound counterintuitive why
does the media
report
differently
well because it's money in reporting the
negative effects almost exclusively
think about
writing a newspaper article
it's really easy to get the population
all gendered up about something like an
opioid crisis overdoses and you don't
even have to tell people
how to keep people safe if you're
talking about overdose you don't even
have to say
why people are dying from overdoses like
overdoses in our country happen largely
because people get contaminated drug
because people are combining sedatives
and they don't know that this enhances
the respiratory depressing effects of
drugs they don't know but when you read
these newspaper articles they don't say
this they don't say how to keep people
safe all they do is frighten the
population
there's money in that and then we think
about people who write tv shows um the
people who write movies
most of the stuff written by drugs is
just [ __ ] um i think about i love
going to watch comedians and the
comedians when they talk about drugs
again most of the things that they say
about drugs
is [ __ ] i mean you can say the
stupidest things about drugs and be
believed you can
write a movie and you don't even have to
develop your characters if you throw
drugs into the mix you say oh he's a
drug dealer you don't have to say
anything about that person's background
or about that person being developed as
a character uh because the population
think they know and when and and the
writer uh is lazy and does not do any
sort of development just just think
about any
oh let's think about the sopranos for
example uh you know they they have a new
program coming out so let's think about
them for a second
the sopranos is a show in which
the lead character tony
kills people for a living that's what he
does right
this character actually made a
sympathetic for him
when he is
besmirching and
denigrating his nephew christopher for
using a drug and we feel
sympathy for tony the character uh who
just killed somebody uh
who is a horrible person but
being a drug user is a worse person
that's what the show wants us to believe
tony's a racist
uh
murderer all of these things but we feel
sympathy for him but we don't feel
sympathy for anyone who uses drugs
that's some crazy [ __ ] i mean and the
american public buys into it that is
that's wild to me and that we all bought
into this crap and that's what we do in
damnit
everything that's in film on television
and it's like what's wrong with you
people
so
you